I swear folks we do not play into both
being read though I do feel like we need
to have a balloon right here good flow
so welcome to council of geeks we have a
bit of bud unexpected to surprise an
actual second roundtable this month
which never happens and also a guy who I
haven't had in front of a camera for
about two and a half years
it's Jason sharer howdy folks yeah age
of Ultron was last that was the last
time um so we are going to talk about it
um and I my thoughts on it are already
on the record I did my review and in
case you did in case you're watching
that without watching this not sure why
that be the case but I thought it was
fine but given how positive most other
people's reaction seems to be that means
that scaled I hate spoilers across this
conversation so minis we are holding
nothing back so V book miniseries yes
just everything is on the table okay so
and I suppose the other thing that's
worth when she get too much further
along you have read the book seen the
miniseries in the movie yes I have seen
the movie I have seen enough breakdowns
of and clips from the miniseries that I
feel like you've seen it but if I'm
being fair I haven't start to finish and
I haven't read the book yeah this
explains a lot about me if you know me I
first read Stephen King when I was nine
years old or a pet sematary that
actually
so much I remember I read it for the
first time in 1989 because it was a
really intimidating book I think it
clocks in at eleven hundred and forty
pages if I remember I it's dense it's
dense because instead of it being about
a haunted house as king has said it's
about a haunted town so I want to talk
about the opening scene first alright
let's talk about the opening so which I
take it as a scene I think it's at least
for me was the most effective one in the
movie yeah
although and I talked about this in my
review I put an asterisks on that
because I don't know how much of that is
how effective the move the scene is in a
vacuum and how much of it it happens to
hit my own particular hot button of
deadly endangered like sub
eight-year-olds that makes me right
deeply uncomfortable it has a thing
right but what I what I loved about that
opening scene was it established that
the movie wasn't going to pull any
punches yeah you know it's because the
miniseries you know of course you have
Tim Curry pop up and he does this thing
with Georgie and it's implied
everything that happens but of course
you know it's a mini series on ABC 1990
I mean how much yeah you know blood and
guts gonna get you get the teeth and
that's about it you don't even see him
bite you just see this yeah come out and
that's the thing too is that he only has
fangs to Jim curry only has fangs
whereas with Pennywise with Bill
skarsgård Pennywise they went as I call
it the Guillermo del Toro route versus
chief teeth teeth teeth teeth teeth
teeth and you know the fact that not
only do you see Georgie you see it
chopped down you see Georgie scurry
and running away with the blood coming
out and then that hand stretches and
pulls him into the sewer I'm like okay I
this is the ride we're going fine yeah
it's it's not gonna pull any punches I
mean we're the miniseries fell short and
what I liked that the movie picked up on
without making explicit is the idea that
it is not just a monster okay you know
in the miniseries you give to the cheesy
scene at the end and it's the spider and
whatnot in the movie you get the sense
that it is truly something else it's not
alien but I mean in the book it is
described as from beyond time and space
is from outside time and space and it
just landed on earth millions upon
millions upon millions of years ago in
that area of Maine yeah and it just
slept yeah until people showed up and it
went Oh food the casting was just
spot-on yeah
Finn I can't remember his last name I
feel terrible I am NOT gonna know any of
these okay so just go with her so the
kid who played Richie he was also
willing stranger things perfectly cast
he got that character down pat the kid
who played Eddie who was also the kid in
Midnight Special
Beverly was like the most transformed
character from book to miniseries to
movie well and again I haven't read the
book but Stephen King he doesn't have
the strongest chops in terms of writing
female characters at least as a
reputation that's not to say that he
writes bad ones but he seems to write
them best as victims or as allegories
not as much as characters very much true
in the 80s and 90s well from early in
his career
I'd say up until about the turn of the
century you know there I actually have a
major problem okay with a change that
they made from the book to the movie
okay so in the book the kids are getting
ready to go into the sewers and for the
because they first had an encounter
with it at the house on the Oh both
street and they were and they heard it
and they said okay if we can hurt it we
can kill it but what ends up happening
is they're planning ends up happening
quicker than they want because Bev's
father finds out she's been hanging out
with all those boys and starts saying I
want to make sure that you're intact
yeah like in the book he it's implied
that he's definitely emotionally abusive
possibly physically abusive but never
sexually abusive because I assumed that
was in the book because it was coming on
so thick that yeah and again I speak as
someone who is mostly seen adaptations
of King as supposed to read him but his
human villains come on real thick at the
very least when adapted to film and I
had assumed that that was a direct
translation from the book yeah you're
telling me that I think wasn't even in
it that makes me more annoyed at it than
irony was she gets chased out of the
house so she runs to the Barrens where
the rest of the losers are and as she
arrives and the rest of the losers are
there Henry shows up okay ready to kill
them because he Henry has finally lost
it at that point Henry does not kill his
dad in the book his dad is not a cop his
dad's just a garden-variety drunk and
he's a neglected kid so I mean we're
gonna this whole conversation is gonna
bounce around so let's talk about Harry
for a second yeah how did he work for
you so so Bowers he started I needed to
see him descend to murder from that
that's what I needed to and I know
here's the thing Kings human villains he
reuses the extreme bully a lot yes and
it's something that at least in terms of
adaptations I've only seen work once and
that was stand by me
yes so when I say Smurl yeah and but
when I see stuff like the Shawshank
Redemption and the psychotic guard or
the mist and
nutty religious woman or hairy bottom
this unlike you I'm not I'm not gonna go
so far as to say people like you don't
exist in the real world but I can't take
you seriously in the character because
you're just you're just this one note
the right the reason ace worked is we
knew he was bad news to begin with but
at first he was just like you know he
trips um he knocks him now and you
realize how bad he is by the time that
movie ends Harry like the second time we
see him he's carving his initials into a
kid's stomach ah yeah but Bowers starts
as a hoodlum a dangerous hoodlum but a
hoodlum and he eventually it's the the
apocalyptic rock fight which is actually
the title of a chapter which they do so
well in the movie but the rock fight is
what causes Henry to snap okay and a
little bit of it whispering in his ear
and so the kids are in the Barrens and
they get chased into the source okay so
basically what happens whereas in this
bev gets kidnapped and turned into the
damsel in distress and I'm like they
didn't need any additional motivation
yeah to go find it I hadn't I hadn't
thought about that
yeah you're right well and in general
it's worth me said like for me the big
part of the movie that works is the kids
yes those kids are all gold just so good
so good and and the dialogue the diamond
on this stand by me dialogue yeah I saw
it where they're just gonna say
insulting each other like they would in
the 80s
I remember those kind of insults of 1980
there you go
what I liked about Bill skarsgård
performance with this is like so you
made the joke from that yeah he sounds a
little bit like shaggy not shaggy yeah
he sounds like scooby doo without the
value without the heart of every word
you know but compare that to Tim Curry's
voice like and Tim Curry portrayal Tim
Curry looks like you know just regular
clown with a you know with this voice
you know like we're gonna do this we all
flow we're a skarsgård you know he keeps
going up and
and he has this maniacal little giggle
mm-hmm which just I'm sorry this kind of
soft for lack of a better term Buffalo
Bill voices creeped me out now you
actually said something that for me is
part of why I feel the movie kind of
fails in the delivery of the horror okay
because what you said was you know it's
just it's just something about you know
those creepy Buffalo Bill voices and the
thing is I don't think the movie does a
very good job at building tension in it
seems I think it banks very heavily on
the imagery that it's using already
being inherently creepy and I am NOT
inherently creeped out by clowns I never
have been and so all these scenes were
happening that I feel like if they had
been done with more care could have made
me afraid of this clown but then I felt
like it was just going whoo spooky calm
and I'm I'm sitting here going okay you
gonna do anything with that to build the
tension because like I think of things
like after I saw jaws I was afraid of
water for a little bit and after I saw
the 1970s invasion of the body snatchers
I was afraid to go to bed after I saw
the Doctor Who episode of Blake statues
creeped me out for them yeah I mean not
none of these things stuck they weren't
like deep fears that I lived with but
for during the watching of it for a
little while after something that I
wasn't afraid of now made me uneasy this
did not do that at all yeah so I feel
like it I feel like the movie was
banking on creepy clowns are creepy
great the job's done there wasn't a lot
there were a few times where they did
try to play with it like when they're
the first senator in the house and on
Neil Boat Street and Pennywise unfolds
himself from the fridge know that there
are a few things but I think that played
more to the strengths of this is a
creepy house and we don't know how this
house works rather than yeah
selling him as a monster there was one
it's when Eddie is escaping the leper
and he gets around the side of the house
he's just about to go out the fence and
instead of Pennywise standing there with
one balloon he's got the whole pyramid
yeah of balloons and I found that to be
a really creepy symbolism because it
ties into and I want to believe this was
a deliberate choice for the filmmakers
part the monument that Pennywise has
built to himself in his lair you know
where it's all the kids toys it's going
up and up and up and up and up and
they're all the kids who are stuck that
might have worked for me again if they
hadn't shown it in the trailers and so I
was already over it so I gave it away as
an image I don't know I I know that when
they make the sequel because you know
spoilers it ends with it chapter one and
I think the fact that it's already made
three hundred million dollars worldwide
guarantees chapter two covering the
adults they will back a truckload of
money up to the writer and directors
house it is it go ahead and make it so
and that I hope they'll just use hiring
actors as opposed to you know well over
CGI well Andy Andy machete the director
has said that a lot of the metaphysical
stuff was cut for budgetary reasons and
he hopes to bring it back and say yes so
now which brings me to something cuz
this was something I I didn't quite get
into an argument as it was over Twitter
and I don't think either of us felt like
going back and forth on it but I know I
got into a disagreement with Ryan daily
about the ending of the movie and
specifically in the way it is defeated
all right so I want to hear what you
thought about that
okay so I mean it starts with the bolt
gun is empty yeah and bill holds it to
his head even wall mike is screaming
that his empty and he pulls it yeah and
it still injures it it's still like the
bolt went through his head which reveals
okay it's the idea of these kids belief
their imagination
those are the things yeah that they have
to use to defeat which then turns into
using a whole hell of a lot of blunt
objects to beat the crap out of them
okay so I take it you weren't a big fan
of them basically just beating this
thing into submission well but they were
kids what else were they going to do
that is why I love this okay so that's
the thing and I feel like I I was free
from the baggage of having read the book
where I loved the fact that they just
beat the Saints and for me it does work
because honestly I didn't read that
bolt-gun moment the way that you did and
I'm not saying that you weren't reading
it correctly as intended the way I read
it was actually that Pennywise was
mocking him like oh it damaged no not
really
yes so I didn't even read that end of it
into it but here's the reason I love
this it's the fact that what it is is
these kids realize that collectively we
just have to stand our ground and all we
have to do is fight back and to me that
makes sense on so many levels because
from the perspective of it basically
it's never been challenged before
because yeah it's entire mode is to
isolate pay terrify pickoff
he has never really had a true challenge
placed against it so the fact that it
probably doesn't even realize his own
vulnerabilities I like that a big part
of why I like it is it beats the hell
out of the alternative because what's
the alternative way to defeat this BS
ritual or MacGuffin device both of which
I don't like especially in a story like
this where you're dealing with kids and
yes I know one of them's a bookworm but
no I'm sorry I would not buy the idea
that he happened to find in the library
something that is a ritual that tells
them how to beat this thing
or from what I come from a miniseries oh
well hit him with silver Wow
what a lucky coincidence that happened
to her like that kind of stuff I hate
but the idea that they stand up against
it just because they have the bravery to
do so and that is enough because these
kids haven't had to be this brave before
but if they do that and they take it on
they step up that will take care of it
by the more I think about it the more I
love
here's why because it's gonna come back
they're gonna have to deal with it again
right that means when they come back and
deal with that as adults they realize
the method that they use to conquer
their fears when they were kids worked
then but it's not really enough because
the problem is more complicated so
they're gonna have to deal with it in a
more complicated fashion in a more adult
fashion and so instead of becoming a
matter of well we did it we tried to
defeat it before with the ritual of chud
or whatever the heck it's called no
those are you know that we tried to do
this thing before but we didn't do it
right or we didn't rip its heart out at
the end or whatever but now we have to
do it again but right instead it's a
matter of we stood up to and just beat
it into submission but that wasn't
permanent so let's do way more mature a
more thoughtful approach and do it right
this time
that to me is the Matic as hell yeah I
love that
yeah the ritual of chug that's one that
they talked about well they cut that
that that's a that's a smokehouse ritual
yeah smoke that they go through another
vision of how it arrived it's kind of BS
MacGuffins and then or at least okay it
will be in a movie again I'm not gonna
judge the book cuz I do understand a lot
of what King does is very difficult to
translate but certainly you translate to
a movie here's where the the movement
from the 50s to the 90s comes into play
okay I think for the kids because it's
so in the book they make the decision to
go after it with silver and the reason
they do that is because they say well it
showed up as a werewolf it's a monster
monsters can always be killed by silver
in the movies so let's use silver and I
get that that's Kenji but boy that's a
happy coincidence it's their belief that
silver can do it okay is what damage is
it just like Eddie jumps at it and the
and in the in the movie they hint at its
true form very very quickly you get
maybe a sec another shot it's when his
arms turn into they're like mantis
spider like nine display
yeah that is its true form at least on
our plane of existence the wear really
exists is where the dead lights exist
but that's a whole different so really
there it's about the belief okay that
it's it's not about you know this is the
magic ritual thing and whatnot
no it's the kids believe just as it
feeds off of belief the belief fear they
are going to use belief to defeat them
now so we move that up to the A's yeah
and if we're gonna deal with it so there
are three movies that are directly
referenced on the Capitol Theater Batman
lethal weapon 2 and Nightmare on Elm
Street 5 yeah how are all of the
villains defeated in those movies they
get the crap kicked that saw their
beaten right awful through those wounds
they get the crap kicked out of them and
the movie also follows the traditional
dead teenager trope of oh I can kill the
teenager if I just get them alone
right that's penalize this constant
strategy if I can get one of the losers
a lot I can kill them so the excellent
question really is you know is it a
horror movie ultimately I'm gonna say
yes I'm not I'm not
Astrix then say that's not all it is it
Devender at least that's not all it's
trying to be but I think to claim that
it's anything other than a horror movie
is to be deeply disingenuous yeah so yes
but I'm but I do hasten to add
that's certainly for its ambition and
again for me it didn't get there but for
its ambition just calling it a horror
movie gives it the short shrift right
but at its core it is at the end of the
day a horror movie
yeah and I I agree with you there and
you know you talked about it's an the
ambition of the movie I think of King
describes in one of his non-fiction
books I think Danse Macabre
he talks about the three levels of
horror there's the gross out
you know which is the land of hostel and
saw were you just looking good yeah
then there's horror where what you see
repulses you you know repulses you
forces you to look away gives you the
chills make you scream whatever but then
there's terror and terror is what Kings
as he always aims for and it's when the
mind cannot comprehend what is implied
when imagination takes over and it shuts
down in self-defense but yet forces
itself to experience what it's trying to
imagine and so that's you know that's
why horror novels always work better
than horror movies right you know it's
yeah he argues okay so you're watching a
movie you're actors is going up the
narrow stairs you know something's gonna
be behind that door at the end of the
stairs and she swings up in the door and
behind the door is a six hook spider in
the audience screams that's not a spirit
of terror is a scream of a relief
because obviously oh six foot spotty I
thank God I thought it's gonna be a 60
foot spider you can put a 60-foot spider
back there pause could be a 600 foot
spider you know you can't win whatever
you can put on screen is not going to
match what you can possibly put in your
mind but I think it was aiming for
terror to try to show you something that
your mind couldn't comprehend like the
the the painting lady that came back
that wasn't that was that was a good
idea I think I was one of the better
instances although again I'm thinking
about it now it comes back to how I feel
like overall the movie may have been
aiming for terror but was banking too
hard on on creepy clown because yes he
appears in the form of penny wise more
times in the movie than he does in the
book and he keeps defaulting back to
penny wise after the initial spook of
whatever it is and out of the kids the
only one that's afraid of clowns is
Ritchie and yet they all keep seeing him
as a clown Brett because creepy clown
clap I mean I think I think that's a
combination of creepy clowns are a
little bit in the zeitgeist right now
and Tim Curry being the most memorable
part of the miniseries yes they did
definitely rely on that
oh one more okay one thing I wanted to
ask what you thought what did you think
of Bev offing her dad I was fine with it
because the hit was so cathartic yeah
and the sound of that
hitting her dad that was that kind of
hit mm-hmm and I actually honestly at no
point really stopped and thought about
it beyond that and I'm thinking about
I'm like I don't know what I think about
that but in the in the moment I didn't
question because I loved that hit some
yeah well I mean it's certainly been
building up to her finally gaining
control of her life
yes so to speak because I mean she dealt
with all the teasing you know very
appropriate of the 80s of oh you're a
[ __ ]
you've done this at the boys and yadi
yadi had a very appropriate dad being
that creepy like a God knows what's
going on behind closed doors and I think
that was why I had such a problem with
her becoming a damsel in distress
because it happens immediately after
that moment she has just completely
taking control of her life
by killing her abusive father with the
top of a toilet tank and she turns and
Pennywise grabs her by the neck and and
smash-cut
yeah Anna smash cut to the losers and I
think that that was what made that her
being kidnapped even worse for me it was
the fact that like yes she's full of his
moment and that bathroom had such
significance with the tribute to the
original Nightmare on Elm Street with
the blood I mean overall I thought it
was a massive massive improvement over
the miniseries in many ways and I think
that's but that's also a product of time
and talent involved I think that has
more to do with that than anything else
I mean Perdiccas production values how
much better performances are much better
yeah the kids are still good in the
miniseries but the kids are even better
in the movie so yeah no I I would say
there's not I would say the miniseries
unless you grew
on it or grew up on television of the
time does not play all know unless
you're nostalgic for that kind of stuff
no yeah unless you're nostalgic and you
want to see you know jonathan brandis
stutter badly and a really really young
Seth Green I'm worried about where
they're going to go with the adults
because as you point out you know they
beat the crap they literally beat the
crap out of it and it falls down into
wherever that hole goes yeah
and so they heard it but we know it's
going to come back so what are they
gonna have to do the second time around
I mean I know what they do in the novel
I cannot possibly see it translating in
in the movie I just can't see it gives
you want to talk about metaphysical like
abstract existential like I mean one
thing I do know that is been confirmed
as any machete he said he does plan to
get all the kids back so even though
that half the story was told pretty
completely in this first movie he does
still plan to bring those kids back for
sections of the second one which from my
understanding of where the strengths of
the story are probably a good idea
because the kids is most people will
freely admit both of the miniseries and
the book the kids stuff is all the best
stuff the kids stuff is absolutely all
the best stuff and you'd better start
shooting quickly cuz you know let's face
it a child actor at 12 and 13 looks like
two completely different people so you
know start shooting tomorrow
but yeah it's I'm just gonna be
interested to see where they go and how
fast they can get it out just for that
very reason of the kids and also I mean
you know let's be honest you know not
losing any steam from this I guess that
they've created well I I have no doubt
that if new line had its way the next
one will be out next year I think
realistically it'll probably be out in
two right because they've they don't
want to make sure they have a script
that they're happy
yeah just what delete this for so long
yes and I have no doubt that as the
anticipation building and they realized
they were gonna make their money back
easy they probably had any machete and
his and his writing support team working
on that already mm-hmm but that you know
especially if they're getting more into
the metaphysical stuff he can't he
probably can't finalize the script until
he knows exactly how much money he has
to work with and even then they're gonna
have to allow for all the CG all the
post-production CGI rendering kind yeah
and and all that stuff which they had
plenty of on this I guess
skarsgård did a lot of his stuff motion
capture green-screen
okay and then they fill him in
afterwards
I don't dislike the movie and there's a
lot of little things about the movie and
the kids are great but it just it just
didn't it just didn't land for me the
way it seems to be landing for the
majority of people so you're the one
reviewer that would bring the Rotten
Tomatoes score from 100 to 99
I got ya that one guy I would that one
guy would have been getting death
threats and who sent to my door and well
that thankfully I'm not an accredited
critic so I can say whatever I want with
no consequences don't prove me wrong I'm
already upon a story every Tuesday but
we don't want that on ya I'm gonna talk
to you about that alright alright so I
think I think we'll wrap it up there
Jason thank you very much for joining me
thank you for having me maybe a part of
the other reason I don't have your back
is you don't have anything to plug do
you you can go to my production
company's website 11:47 productions.com
check out what i'm working on in terms
of photography blog writing a movie I'm
trying to get off the ground so hi wow
you have a lot more to plug oh there
will be a link in the description so if
you are watching this in video form you
can listen to an uncut version of this
conversation more or less uncut it's a
version of this conversation on the
council of geeks podcast feed available
on iTunes and stitcher
in any case folks thanks so much for
joining us thank you Jason thank you the
thing and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]